foreign
or an imminent threat of flood waters
entering your home call 111 immediately
if it's flooded forget it the less
urgent issues with drainage in your
street or roads overflowing or for any
other issues please phone the council
service center during periods of extreme
weather we triage our calls and attend
to the most urgent ones first
cancel civil defense Response Team visit
affected properties and help where
needed if you encounter Fudd water treat
it as if it's contaminated don't plan it
and wash your hands thoroughly
afterwards if you do come into contact
we also deploy sucker trucks and pumps
in flood-prone areas to help protect
property as much as we can
foreign